[Music]  h-how'd if you heard about this story  but earlier this week a woman at an  Atlanta Airport was detained by TSA so  they could search her afro for search  her search her afro for weapons and  explosives yeah and I was watching TV  this morning and I saw an interview with  the woman she seemed really upset but  personally as I was watching the  interview I thought I think the TSA is  just doing its job  check out my hair is Isis Brantley on a  trip home to Dallas this week says she  made it through an airport security  checkpoint with TSA officers chased her  down hey you hey you ma'am ma'am stop  stop she agreed to let them search her  hair for weapons  she started petting my hair and I was  like in tears at that point as she  [Applause]